auj tu as dix minutes
oui j'ai plus qu'à canadiens tués
battait comme un homme maintenant papa
éviter niaiseries d'accord tu peux
fermer la porte
oui tu peux fermer la porte on va à la
chasse à l'université rendons ce voyage
spécial nous sommes complets ce soir est
par exemple au cela elle n'est pas
disponible
on dirait qu'elle est disponible oui
mais non c'est nul à mon esprit fini par
revenir sur mes études tous mes amis
avaient réussi cry pêcheurs à travailler
à la maison blanche
jason a field avaient monté un fonds
spéculatif
billy wilder a vendu son entreprise de
technologies de pointes à 40 ans
qu'est-ce que j'ai moi je travaille pour
nos bnl et il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire à tort on m'a demandé
de tes nouvelles
tu sais où la ville avait mené je me
souviens de ce gars brad penny fort
quand sur toi je les aime ce sont des
écoles prestigieuses droid essaie de ne
pas trop mettre la pression d'accord
vont conseiller dit que je serais pris
dans n'importe quelle université monfils
harvard pas on verra si ça se fait mon
fils est un musicien très talentueux il
compose aussi ses propres morceaux donc
merveilleux je suis presque certain car
farde lui convient parfaitement
vous pensez qu harvard lui convient tout
d'un coup mes pensées se sont assombries
treuil pourrait très bien finir avec les
mêmes problèmes que moi mais c'est
harvard tu sais même les génies sont
recalés il faut qu'on fasse le maximum
je suis sur le point de passer mon
entretien tu as besoin de me sauter à la
gorge la juste maintenant tu es
complètement folle tu sais
l'air blasé à ton âge avait de grands
idéaux comme toi et n'importe lequel de
tes amis ici vous avez 50 ans et vous
croyez encore que le monde a été fait
pour vous j'ai 47 ans moi j'ai peur que
les gens me voient comme un raté oh oui
c'est vrai tu as ton truc c'est quelque
chose de très louable d'ailleurs c'est
une excellente initiative
c'est tes amis en l'air nul tout le
monde ne pense qu'à soi même la seule
personne qui pense à toi c'est moi
en effet cet enfant avec aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un de bien et de brillants
je suis fier de toi
ça
[Applaudissements]
papa tu es en train de faire une
dépression ou quoi
[Musique]